[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan.
And this week I'm at
AnDevCon in Boston.
But that's not going to
stop me from giving you
your update about the coolest
developer news from Google
in the last week.
Say goodbye to CanvasHacks
and animated GIFs.
Yes, I said "ghif."
Let's just move on.
Muted AutoPlay for video
is supported by Chrome
for Android as of Version 53.
Playback starts
for a video element
once it comes into view if both
AutoPlay and Muted are set.
And it can be initiated
programmatically.
Details and code on the post
linked in the description
below.
The latest version of the
Google Maps Android API
is now out with more
developer-requested features,
including the ability to
track camera movements more
accurately, set the
minimum and maximum zoom
levels on your map, and
restrict the user's panning
to particular lat-long
bounds of the camera target.
More details on the post.
Android add-ons
for Docs and Sheets
are a new way to get more
work done from anywhere,
such as writing a contract
for esignature with your phone
or pulling in CRM data on your
tablet for some quick analysis.
For examples and links
to the developer preview
documentation,
check out the post.
To help you design and improve
monetization as a mobile game
developer, here are five tips
to improve game-as-a-service
monetization with best practice
examples from mobile games
publisher Kongregate.
More than 13 million people
now use the Hello English app
developed by CultureAlley to
help Indians learn English
through gamification.
Check out the video to learn
how they use Google Play
tools to address varying levels
of connectivity and device
capabilities and
improve user retention.
6 out of 10 internet
users in the US start
shopping on one
device but continue
or finish on a different one.
Cross-device conversions already
help you measure these customer
paths.
Using the same technology, we've
introduced three new reports
in the attribution
section of AdWords.
These provide deeper
insight into device usage
along the full search
conversion path.
Diagrams and details
are on the post.
AdWords Editor 11.5 is now
available to all advertisers
globally.
The update includes
support for expanded text
ads and mobile app
engagement ads;
import, export, and simultaneous
posting from multiple accounts;
and much more.
Want to know how to avoid
lock-in with your cloud
provider by selecting
open-source software that
can run on a variety of clouds?
Check out the two
parts of this post
for a discussion and some
practical getting-started
specifics.
Google Cloud Shell is a
command-line interface
that allows you to manage
your Google Cloud Platform
infrastructure from any computer
with an internet connection.
We're happy to announce
that Cloud Shell is now
generally available
and still free to use.
Also now generally available
are customer-supplied encryption
keys for Compute
Engine, allowing
you to take advantage
of the cloud
while protecting your Google
Compute Engine disks with keys
that you control.
More details on both of these
updates are on their posts--
you got it-- linked below.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Don't forget to subscribe.
You never know
where we'll be next.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]